sorry sorry sorry
is this happening
what or did the pawn
go to g3 and it's a display error what i
need confirmation
how many could be he's a bit renowned
for checking g4 say say what one more
time i think is you you're supposed to
take your q and and tell me to say what
one more time but
[Laughter]
but seriously what
[Laughter]
what the hell is this
i mean it's like
a c4 e6 in this position
g3 has been played a lot
g4 is new
i'm sure someone's done it but i've
never seen this
i mean it's slightly stronger than d4
knight f6 g4 without the inclusion of c4
e6 i'll give you i'll give you this much
because
well i mean after that takes g4 e4 you
cannot play d6 with within immediately
winning positions
you go f3 3 attack
attack yeah
so what's this point if we take the pawn
oh it has to be four i mean if you do if
you don't play four here what have you
done
even if you do play e4 but no this is
this is amazing
chakri and mommy are stealing this show
instantly
i should